[Música]
las naciones más endeudadas del mundo
buscan alivio financiero este tema ha
sido una constante en cumbres de de
líderes como el g20 o la reunión de los
46 países menos desarrollados del mundo
Naciones Unidas estima que 54 naciones
necesitan alivio inmediato para evitar
un aumento en la pobreza extrema pero la
pandemia por el Coby 19 y las altas
tasas de interés que imponen los
organismos financieros han provocado
déficit extremos en los gobiernos esto
ha llevado a pedidos de que se reforme
el sistema vamos a tener una
conversación sobre esta materia con
Alberto bernale quien es director de
estrategia global de XP investments y
también está en el estudio de France 24
la periodista de economía Daniela
Blandón Un saludo para ambos eh Daniela
Alberto y si les parece comenzamos con
las preguntas
entonces Alberto el fondo monetario
internacional el Banco Mundial y el
banco de desarrollo chino son los
principales organismos prestamistas del
mundo pero las altas tasas de interés de
los dos primeros que mencioné se
consideran abusivas por qué lo son y se
verán obligados a hacer una reforma
Pues a ver yo pensaría que que yo yo
haría un Matiz en eso que acabas de
decir yo no pensaría que son abusivas
esas esos esa esos esas dos
instituciones dan unas tasas de interés
muchísimo más Bajas comparadas con las
que existirían para los países
endeudados con problemas si tuviesen que
ir a pedir dinero en los mercados
financieros
por ejemplo en el caso Déjame Darte Un
ejemplo muy específico de de en el caso
de Argentina si uno hace el ponderado de
las tasas de interés de las deudas que
tiene contra el fondo monetario
internacional tú llegas unos niveles de
tasas quizás de tres y medio cuatro por
ciento en este momento si si Argentina
tuviese que salir a emitir deuda en este
momento en los mercados internacionales
tendría que tendría que pagar unas tasas
muy seguramente cercanas al 20% Entonces
sería obviamente una algo que
simplemente no es viable desde el punto
de vista
porque un país pues no puede pagar unas
tasas del 20% porque los países no
crecen su pib nominal en gran parte a
estas tasas del 20% en dólares Entonces
sería una situación de en la cual
explotaría la la tasa de deuda contra
pib entonces no es viable Entonces yo en
ese sentido Obviamente que uno podría
decir que ojalá fuesen las tasas más
bajas pero pero yo sería una un Matiz en
términos de de que de qué tan altos son
las tasas que ofrecen esas dos entidades
señor Bernal pero también así como el
fondo monetario internacional ofrece
mejores tasas que el sistema financiero
también cuando llega un país lo hace con
condiciones yo le presto pero con
determinadas condiciones porque son tan
impopulares que es lo que llega pidiendo
el fondo monetario a los países para
poderles hacer esos préstamos más
asequibles
pues es que es importante tener en
cuenta que el fondo monetario
internacional es un banco
al igual que el Banco Mundial igual que
el banco interamericano de desarrollo en
el caso del Banco Mundial y el banco
interamericano de desarrollo la
condicionalidad es menor pero a ver
déjame Darte Un ejemplo muy específico
Daniela sobre sobre Qué sería una
condicionalidad en el caso del préstamo
Y ese esa condicionalidad existe digamos
en el caso del préstamo que le das el
fondo monetario internacional a
Argentina que es básicamente Yo te
presto te presto el dinero pero con la
condición de que en los próximos cinco
años Tú logres pasar de un déficit O sea
que básicamente tú gastes más de lo que
recibes a que tengas un superávit que
básicamente gastes menos a lo que
recibes para qué Para que tengas la
capacidad de
de pagar las deudas que tienes esto es
básicamente como si yo voy a mañana un
banco X en Latinoamérica y estado y el
banco me pide los estados financieros de
la familia y me pide cuánto gano y me
pide cuánto gasto etcétera y que Cuáles
son los activos que yo tengo para qué
para saber si yo le voy a pagar de
vuelta al banco Entonces digamos que en
el caso del fondo monetario
internacional es lo mismo que hace un
banco con cualquier cliente privado Solo
que agrandado a niveles de país entonces
Claro que hay una condicionalidad Y
claro que todo esto genera mucha
digamos hay hay mucha reacción negativa
muchas de estas decisiones Por qué Pues
porque implica que se gaste menos por
definición
afecta a algunos sectores de la sociedad
o que se recaude más implica que si
tienen que subir los impuestos y pues a
nadie le gusta pagar impuestos y a la
gente le gusta más que el gobierno gaste
a que no gaste
En todo caso cada vez más países se
enfrentan una crisis de liquidez Cómo
podrían salir de este tema teniendo en
cuenta pues el factor de los
prestamistas internacionales
si en este momento tenemos una coyuntura
muy específica porque el Banco Central
más importante del mundo que es la
reserva Federal pues ha seguido subiendo
tasas de interés en una forma muy
importante Entonces cuando el Banco
Central más importante del mundo sube
las tasas de interés quiere decir que
el resto de los países del mundo se ven
obviamente
afectados por ese movimiento entonces
hoy le está costando muchísimo más
dinero a una persona o a un gobierno
digamos endeudarse en Brasil en Colombia
en Chile en gran parte porque endeudarse
en Estados Unidos está costando
muchísimo más no se nos olvide que hace
apenas dos años la tasa de interés de
intervención en Estados Unidos era del
0% 0 por ciento ya estamos llegando al
5% entonces todo lo que se compra en la
economía todo lo que se lo que lo que
tengan que endeudar son los gobiernos
etcétera
hoy en día están pagando unas tasas de
interés muchísimo más altas y por qué
están las tasas de interés más altas
Pues porque después de la pandemia y
todos los efectos atados a la pandemia
hemos tenido pues una explosión de
consumo y unos problemas muy importantes
desde el punto de vista de la oferta
mundial de productos y hemos tenido este
problema inflacionario tan importante
Entonces desde desafortunado digamos que
la pandemia nos enfermó obviamente y lo
que estamos viendo hoy en términos de
mayor inflación y mayores tasas de
interés es el el efecto secundario
de esa pandemia pues ya que está
básicamente de salida pero que
obviamente tuvo efectos muy importantes
y quizás lo va a tener lo va a seguir
teniendo efectos por por lo mal por lo
menos un par de trimestres más
señor Bernal cómo le podemos explicar a
la gente de a pie una persona como yo
cómo se ve afectada porque el gobierno
está muy endeudado y cuáles son los
casos más dramáticos en América Latina
pues Daniela básicamente lo que la forma
como yo lo explicaría es la siguiente
primero que todo el gobierno Somos todos
todos los que pagamos impuestos somos
Dueños del gobierno entonces todo lo que
lo que ocurre en el gobierno nos afecta
directamente a nosotros Entonces es un
tema muy importante el segundo tema
importante es que entre más endeudado
esté el país más riesgoso es ese país
Por qué Porque los inversionistas miran
y dicen por ejemplo déjame darte un
ejemplo Argentina
o Venezuela o el Salvador entonces la
gente mira y dice este país pues creo
que tiene muchas oportunidades quizás me
vaya muy bien en mi negocio Pero tiene
una tiene una serie de obligaciones
financieras financieras muy complicadas
o sea debe muchísimo dinero y volvemos
otra vez a la analogía de que yo vaya
mañana a un banco en Latinoamérica o en
Estados Unidos no importa y entonces la
persona que me va a dar el crédito Mira
mi mi perfil y dice este señor como que
se endeudó mucho en los últimos siete
años quizás no vaya a tener la capacidad
de repagarme mi deuda o si la O si la O
si la me la va a repagar Pues sí pero
tiene más riesgo Entonces le voy a
cobrar una tasa de interés más alta por
qué Porque entre mayor sea la tasa de
interés más se cubre el inversionista
ante la posibilidad de que no le vuelvan
a pagar por el dinero que está prestando
entonces así es como afecta esto todo a
las personas del común entre mayores
sean las tasas de interés todo cuesta
más por eso es que la inflación es más
alta en Argentina en Venezuela etcétera
y y porque y básicamente hay una entre
más te cobren a ti por Prestarte tu
dinero el dinero que necesitas para para
hacer un emprendimiento o lo que sea
pues más difícil va a ser sacar ese
emprendimiento adelante otra vez por el
que la tasa de interés es mucho más alta
entonces lo mejor que le puede pasar a
latinoamérica es que las tasas de
interés sean bajas como digamos como en
los países nórdicos pues la tasa de
interés que le cobran a Finlandia los
bancos o los inversionistas es muy baja
lo mismo con noruego lo mismo con Suiza
con Suecia Por qué Porque son países que
tienen una estabilidad fiscal de Pues
que que genera envidia de la buena en
Latinoamérica desafortunadamente no
tenemos eso todavía pero pues Dios
quiera que eventualmente si lo logremos
bien Alberto Bernal director de
estrategia global de XP investments
gracias a usted por su análisis y por
las explicaciones pertinentes
con muchísimo gusto Hasta luego Saludos
a la audiencia y Daniela gracias a usted
también Vamos a continuar hacemos una
pequeña pausa ya volvemos con más de
directo a América
[Música]